Speaker 1: Let's start today with the US-Mexico
border. No matter how many times the right wingers
say it. The US-Mexico border is not open under Joe
Biden. Now, you might be saying, David, of course
it's not open. How could anyone believe that
it is open? There are millions of people based
on polling that believe the border is open under
Joe Biden as a result of some change or series of
changes that were put in place when Donald Trump
left and when Joe Biden became the president of
the United States. This is not true. And we're
going to look at it right now. And the reason
we're going to look at it is it's good to once get
everything on the record so that in the future,
when this talking point comes up, when the MAGA
people call me on the Friday show and they say,
but the border is open, that's one of the problems
I have with Joe Biden. We can now create a record,
a reference point to go through the various
elements of this because this is a I would call it
relatively common assertion perpetuated by right
wing media, by right wing politicians. And it is
flowing down to just random right wing voters.
The claims are numerous. One of the claims that's
often used to say the border is open is you will
hear things like We are catching so many people at
the border because Biden opened it. By definition,
if we are catching people, if we are stopping
people, if we are taking people into custody, by
definition, the border is not open. Now, when you
want to look at has policy changed, have numbers
changed, is there something tangible maybe with
the wall or with border agents that Joe Biden has
changed? You find that very little has actually
changed. The Biden administration has increased
the capacity of shelters and processing centers at
the border to better manage the flow of migrants.
But that's not evidence of an open border. It's
evidence of being able to more quickly and more
efficiently say who is merely crossing illegally
and needs to be put into sort of the deportation
flow and who is seeking asylum and needs to be
put into that bureaucratic process. Neither of
those are evidence that the border is open. In
addition to that, there are border security
claims. Biden demolished border security.
There's no evidence of that. And you can find each
aspect of this widely documented by the relevant
agencies. Funding requests for Customs and Border
Protection under Biden are almost identical to
under Trump when it comes to how much money is
being requested by the respective administrations
for border security in general staffing levels.
And you say, Oh, well, Trump had way more Border
Patrol than Biden. That's absolutely not the case.
U.S. Border Patrol staffing levels were slightly
higher under Obama, around 21,000 total.
Under Trump, they were in the 19,000 range,
plus or minus a few hundred border agents under
Biden. They're in that same 19,000 range plus or
plus or minus a few hundred. So staffing levels,
identical funding requests, essentially identical.
Beyond that, what about policy? What about
policy on turning people around or taking asylum
requests or whatever the case may be? Border
authorities, you may be shocked to hear under
Biden are enforcing immigration laws just like
under Trump. Immigrants continue to be expelled,
detained or allowed in based on the same
standard as to whether they are passing
initial screenings and what exactly their business
in the United States is. The Biden administration,
although they did stop construction of the
wall. Few hundred miles of wall. The Biden
administration is repairing all existing border
barriers, adding detection technology to make it
easier for Border Patrol to identify where do we
need to go? I'm not even telling you these things
because I like or dislike them. I'm just telling
you what the truth is about border policy. It is
absolutely the case that Biden hasn't added any
new barriers, which I think is the right policy,
because the wall was quite a silly idea. But Joe
Biden is fully funding the repair of existing
barriers that were already there. So you have two
groups of people. You have people that are coming
to, quote, sneak in as the traditional illegal
immigration is sort of characterized. And then
you have people coming to seek asylum. And then
in addition to that, you do have people who are
coming over for work legally or coming over for
work illegally, but then going back to Mexico.
There's all of these different scenarios. All of
those categories are being handled the same way
that they were being handled under Donald Trump.
You can agree with the policy or disagree with it.
You can say we should have some kind of permanent
status for so-called Dreamers or we should not.
You can say I like the wall or I don't like the
wall. Fine. Everybody is entitled to that opinion.
But in order to really talk about this, we have to
acknowledge that funding hasn't materially changed
from Trump to Biden. Border staffing hasn't
materially changed from Trump to Biden. Joe Biden
is repairing existing border barriers. Joe Biden
is funding new detection technology for areas of
the border that are that are more remote. And as
far as policy goes, we have the Title 42 thing
which Trump put in. And then Biden is
looking, getting rid of it, but it's
not clear whether it will. So there's that.
But beyond that, we have evidence of nothing
more than another completely fabricated talking
point. That's the truth. The border is not open